the olympic games are usually reserved
for athletes at the top of their sport
but what if you tried to do all the
events yourself
one british pair is trying to complete
and compete in every sport on the tokyo
schedule
from rhythmic gymnastics i like this to
pole vaulting
and even show jumping so far they have
finished
i know we're laughing before we even see
the piece so they've completed 30 events
and they have more to go with just a
week left as mts taeb shows us
this feat is raising money for a cause
very close to their hearts
49 sports
96 events
[Music]
stuart bates and charlotte nichols are
attempting the seemingly impossible
by competing in their own version of the
tokyo games
in which they're the only athletes to
raise money for a cure
to lou gehrig's disease also known as
als
i lost my brother to this terrible
disease 10 years ago when we wanted to
do
something massive that's never been done
before we came up with this absolutely
ridiculous idea
of doing every olympic event in the 17
days of the tokyo games
they're calling it the spendy olympics
in honor of bates's brother spencer
who was an olympic super fan
the fundraising challenge for their
two-person summer games
isn't for the faint of heart slow down
billy
this way and comes with its fair shares
of scrapes
and bruises oh
yeah we're good would you fall off a
horse like that it's not a small part of
your worry oh my heart
stopped i was like yeah that's it spend
the olympics done i think we worry about
each other more than yeah
there was a slight sort of oh my god
what's happening when i saw him get back
up i was like okay here we go again next
event
yeah i'm a tough cookie i bounce yeah
yeah yeah this is mentally demanding
physically
demanding um and it took a lot of
planning as well
yeah all of those things um but the the
reason behind it is
the most driving force
bailey stop ambitious endeavor has
earned them fans from across england
i think it's great we couldn't make it
to tokyo but we were nabbing them
after months of training and advice from
dozens of
former and current olympians
on everything from cycle racing to
windsurfing
in the english countryside the couple
say they have the physical endurance
needed to complete
all the sporting events but there are
other obstacles yes i have a massive
failure of fish as ridiculous as that
sounds and
when we were out practicing then there
was a big horrible dead fish floating on
the water just by my board and it was
all a bit dramatic but
look we got back in and we managed the
race and i'm really glad that we managed
to get there
i mean you shook that off really quickly
had to be done look we can't do
95 events and not the windsurfing can we
so and your wood gold
yeah going for gold then the dozens of
events
only come second to raising money
they've already received more than 40
000 in donations we'll carry on
until there's a cure until there are
treatments we'll keep doing things if
people want us to do the winter spend
olympics or
or anything we'll yeah we'll take things
on
[Music]
a tribute by two amateur athletes
with olympic-sized hearts cbs this
morning
in fiona's tired oxfordshire
i love everything about the spending
olympics everything
you can just tell they're a fun couple
others that they don't take themselves
so seriously clearly but they're also
having a good fun in honor of his
brother
really nice i love charlotte's landing
on the vault that was my favorite
goodness but they made it to abington